pas un jour sans un bombardement et
depuis plus d'un an au Ricky sur le
front sud et pilonné sans relâche par
l'artillerie russe la ville avant-guerre
de 15000 habitants et détruite à 80%.
ils ne sont plus qu'une poignée à y être
resté accroché au peu qu'il leur reste
le temps d'une accalmie quelques miches
de pain pour la plupart des anciens pour
survivre au quotidien
Maria attend son tour pour la
distribution
je viens juste d'avoir deux pains
aujourd'hui parfois les pompiers en
amènent plus vous devez venir filmer
chez moi
elle habite à deux pas dans la localité
il n'y a plus haut ni l'électricité en
un an bombe 04 rue sont tués une
quarantaine d'habitants et fait plus de
200 blessés sa maison a été frappée à
deux reprises
ce n'était pas comme ça la première fois
que ma maison a été bombardée les
fenêtres ont juste explosées maintenant
les murs se sont effondrés aussi je n'ai
jamais vu ça avant c'est si effrayant
il y a deux jours une bombe larguée de
500 kg à éventrer le jardin de son
voisin Youri ce sont des Russes qui ont
fait ça depuis plusieurs semaines c'est
l'aviation qui frappe lourdement et ici
pas de défense entière il y a une trop
près des lignes russes situées à
quelques kilomètres
au moins je voudrais que l'armée
ukrainienne les pousse plus loin des
villages autour d'ici
parce que c'est comme si les Russes
étaient assis dans notre jardin
ils doivent les repousser plus vite
parce que si vous attendent encore pour
être prêt à les repousser il ne restera
plus rien à orife
prise au piège des duels d'artillerie et
sous la menace des chasseurs bombardiers
ceux qui ne sont pas partis se taire
dans l'espoir de voir la guerre enfin
s'éloigner
j'ai un grand sac de pain pour vous
horrible ses environs situés en terrain
plat favorable à une avancée des blindés
est un nœud stratégique pour libérer les
territoires occupés
avec l'annonce d'une possible
contre-offensive ukrainienne les
bombardements russes dans ces villages
ici à proximité de la ligne de front de
zapporisa s'intensifie tous ces sperme
que cette Persée ukrainienne
interviennent le plus vite possible afin
que cesse leur calvaire